[Musik]
strafanstalt hindelbank hier wurde
ursula biondi als 17-jährige eingesperrt
ohne gerichtsurteil zusammen mit
mörderinnen zwecks nach herz jung wurde
sie so genannte administrativ versorgt
ihr vergehen junge liebe und
schwangerschaft
ich finde einfach die konsequenzen
sind die xxi
[Musik]
sich einfach wie überlebt man solche
behördenwillkür und kann man das stigma
hindelbank jemals ablegen
davon handelt dieser films
ursula biondi wurde 1949 als tochter
einer schweizerin und eines italieners
in zürich geboren
mit der heirat verlor ihre muter das
schweizer bürgerrecht
[Musik]
die junge familie war arm und bewohnte
eine kleine dachwohnung an der zürcher
vorschlag genannt wird ohne über kurs
und haben mit das ist schlafzimmer
gesehen das läuft wie man sie von einer
älteren dame nicht läuft wie möglich die
wohnung ist natürlich sehr klicks und
sich aber notwendig sie wir italiener
sind haben wir kein nutzerschaft soul
ikone hat den mgv chronik datiert und
drei module als kindheit war bis zu
ihrem elften lebensjahr glücklich doch
in den 60er jahren verschärfte sich der
ton gegenüber ausländern ursula wurde
plötzlich von klassenkameraden als sau
zink beschimpft um in der schweiz
bleiben zu können musste familie biondi
eingebürgert werden
gleichzeitig wurde aus dem kleinen
mädchen eine schöne junge frau der die
buben in scharen nach liefen so dass
vater hatte angst ein schlechter ruf der
tochter könnte die einbürgerung der
familie gefährden und vertrieb immer wie
ein kapitel mit der flirt mit öffnet
immer weg den die brics person also also
ihren vater hatte beachtet dass der mir
halt einfach schön youtube aber ich habe
es immer verstanden hat mir machen aber
noch freuen
sie hat das einfach 80 stunden und bin
natürlich immer in konflikt als im
jahresschnitt akzeptiert und verstanden
und er hat er hat einfach wäre
das war ganz ruhig sieht dass man so
schnell wie möglich beendet werden
der überforderte vater wusste nicht wie
er mit seiner rebellierenden tochter
umgehen sollte und schlug sie
natürliche barriere für diese barrieren
das heißt einmal mehr hund lebt muss
barrieren oder frage wieso gibt es gott
ich habe zum ziel führt wie soll das
glücklich dass ich frage wo man nicht
stellt der mitte zieht als jugendliche
entweder löschtrupp wie viele
jugendliche sind ja abgestottert referee
media belgischen zeitung der die
konflikte mit dem vater eskalierten
er schlug sie immer heftiger drohte er
mit dem messer sie heute ab kam in ein
mädchenheim heute wieder ab und
begegnete eines tages in niederdorf
einem sieben jahre älteren geschiedenen
mann ich mich beklagen dass ihre zeit
wieder opsec fellini tonnen und das
stinkt ihm etwas machen und faktor von
wieso macht die heißt carlos spanier
schlaf und so ist denn los ist dass die
große liegt dass ich minipics im zwingli
amischen zürich der 60er jahre hatte das
paar keine chance er hatte nach der
scheidung ein zweijähriges heiratsverbot
und sie war mit 16 noch minderjährig
mit riskiert einfach wie das meiste
arbeit krank ist riskiert gab bis zu 57
schweizer grenze nach italien gehen war
home for christmas tree wie lästig sie
wieder ran rose worauf und ja und jetzt
sind sie dann schwanger wurde geht das
heißt mir ein kopfball vom hauptmarkt
dass ich vorne wie das muss das hat dass
ich auch wieder bezeichnet für die
selber generationen es hat sehr viel
jugend frauen und männer wo sie sich
zeit und event aus dem familiäre jochum
machen ist die familie verpasste anna
ist wahr geworden ich habe mir gehört
und habe es im bereich kann dadurch
werden per interpol gesucht wird also
wir sind wirklich oft flucht in genua
war die flucht zu ende und das paar
wurde für immer getrennt
die hochschwangere ursula wurde auf
beschluss der amtsvormundschaft zum
schutz des ungeborenen kindes in die
geschlossene erziehungsanstalt
hindelbank eingewiesen
die eltern unterschrieben auf druck der
behörde die einweisung in der hoffnung
sie vom kindesvater fernzuhalten
sie wussten nicht dass hindelbank im
frauengefängnis war in dem die mädchen
zusammen mit straffälligen frauen
eingesperrt worden
im arbeitsbereich durch rotation der
arbeitsstätte und dem hof in bremen mit
dem zimmer holen
die eltern mussten für den aufenthalt
ihrer tochter über 6000 franken bezahlen
sie glaubten die schwangere tochter
erhalte eine ausbildung im haushalt und
säuglingspflege als die mutter beim
ersten besuch merkte dass die
erziehungsanstalt ein gefängnis war
konnte sie die einweisung nicht mehr
rückgängig machen
ursula brachte ihren sohn im gefängnis
zur welt er wurde er direkt nach der
geburt weggenommen
der vormund des kindes versuchte sie zur
adoption zu überreden
zur ablenkung wurde sie jeden tag zehn
stunden in die gefängnis waschküche
gesteckt sie mir aber vorstellen ihre
schaut sich weg ihres neugeborenen ist
weg und sie sind im casino und sie
machen zwangsarbeit und jetzt plötzlich
merke sie die aussichtslosigkeit und die
selben moment bevor ich überhaupt die
gedankenspiele und die ruhe finden
bin ich losgeworden tiefsten punkt
wirklich ausmacht von romören wo das so
stimmt unternehmer von george michael
ich weiß noch ich bin auf wie im zweiten
lauf banken stört gebracht und du die
ganze woche hat ihre frau einen knopf
[Musik]
wieso heißt das gemacht
ich bin gott abgeführt wurde dritter ist
ganz schön und die sagte goss ruine
handlichen es laufe nach der geburt
bemerkt sie nach dem schlafen und habe
mich zurück aber durch glückliche
umstände und den einsatz einer beherzten
diakonissen bekam obersuhler ihren sohn
nach drei monaten zurück sie musste aber
noch weitere fünf monate mit ihrem baby
im gefängnis verbringen
[Musik]
ich sage immer die richtige schaffen wir
das aber so viel hindelbank kremper
geordnet grundsteuer hat labbadia im
konkubinat so viele sind schwangerschaft
abbrechen
viele machen wo damals junge frau weg
spät wurde nicht traumatisiert konnte
ursula hindelbank nach einem jahr
verlassen
der vater ihres kindes war unauffindbar
sie wollte weg aus zürich und konnte in
genf eine ausbildung machen zur fan von
computern noch karten
sie zog mit ihrem sohn in die
westschweiz und versuchte hindelbank zu
vergessen
[Musik]
im moment sieht man ich mich bereit für
kaka sorgen
tolles rennen vergessen dass klebte
mehrere täter haben ich mache das sind
einfach immer die schwang kriegen sie
das teil von magath hat dann kann ich
mir vorstellen wieder einfacher weg wird
zumal beschlag das mach ich zwischen
dinge immer wieder traurig was man mit
so viel druck machte
ursula biondi war knapp 20 und bekam in
genf eine chance auf ein neues leben
sie verliebte sich in den bekannten
rennfahrer florian fels heiratete und
bekam mit ihm noch eine tochter
ihr mann adoptierte den kleinen boys
endlich hatte sie ihre eigene familie
als oberste pc kursleiterin für das
international labour office der uno in
genf bildete sie tausende von
mitarbeitern aus
jahrelang müsse der schmerz vertrag die
wirtschaft und was ich der u6 sie dass
sie auch von regionalbanken und die
geräte der auslöser ich immer wieder
höre ich immer wieder eigentlich immer
falsch immer brav sieht als sie haben
gerade aber das kann uns wenig erreicht
immer mehr reiche ich wollte so viel
erreichen dass ich das gefühl haben ich
habe es geschafft aber dann reden sie
sich über 30 das gang nach einigen
jahren ging die ehe in die brüche
heute wohnt ursula biondi wieder in
zürich mit ihrem zweiten ehemann einem
anwalt und richter der sie in ihrem
kampf um ihre rehabilitierung und eine
wiedergutmachung stets unterstützte sie
heute geschlossen war und sie hatten
strache muss bekräftigt sind also alles
was etwas umbrachte
das passiert halt einfach finden sie das
haben wir nicht akzeptieren da setzt
sich zur wehr setzen
knapper als gedacht bis 1981 war die
administrative versorgung ohne
gerichtsentscheid in der schweiz gang
und gäbe
erst mit der ratifizierung der
europäischen menschenrechtskonvention
verpflichtet sich die schweiz diese
praxis abzuschaffen
doch bis heute leiden zehntausende still
für sich an der dadurch entstandenen
traumatisierung und stigmatisierung wenn
das nicht teile wie kriegsopfer oder wie
manche wo katastrophe naturkatastrophe
hinter sich
einmal im monat besucht ursula biondi
ihre beiden kinder inkl
[Musik]
die tochter unter dem blick dass er das
geld lieber wie mir das erlaubt ein
miteinander der unterschiedlichen
tochter bei mir wegen der papiere weg
minute und wieder gesehen
das ist natürlich ein unterschied von
der wut über haben
als beruhigend
[Musik]
für den
der richter
[Musik]
ganz bietet ihre zweite chance und ich
sage mir immer unterschied zu zürich
damals ich für mich sie eine stiefmutter
mich sehr klebte und kämpfen bereich
olli türe und tore geöffnet
aus dem im gefängnis geborenen preis ist
ein erfolgreicher unternehmer und
familienvater geworden wie es mehr ganz
ganz ruhig und verwirkliche volkan noch
möglich ist
wenn sie wenn sie am telefon schwächer
wie ruhige stadt dass sie moralische
wiedergutmachung und der
entschuldigungen öffentliche
entschuldigung fordert
ich habe im übrigen steht am anfang und
ich sage ja ich verstehe was du machst
am anfang kann ich das auch vergessen
und nur die mehr darüber reden will der
fonds im rose und macht wenn und aber
jetzt verstanden die ganze das ganze
konzept und jetzt bestätigt dass sie das
fragt und sich eine dabei wie sie seit
jetzt sind sie füllt der kraft vor
andere lebt wo da sind und jetzt
verstehe ich das gut
ihre beiden kinder geben ursula biondi
viel kraft die beziehung zu ihren
eigenen eltern ist aber immer noch sehr
getrübt seit über 40 jahren versucht man
nicht mehr über die vergangenheit zu
reden und keinen streit zu provozieren
ihre beiden schwestern hatten während
der belastenden ein wirkungszeit keine
probleme mit dem vater ursula aber fühlt
sich bis heute von ihm unverstanden und
ungerecht behandelt sie besucht ihre
eltern jeweils mit gemischten gefühlen
[Musik]
es ist schwierig sie der vater sie fotos
oder sie haben die fans drauf hat raab
hat sich kathrin frau bittet sie wird
das hat er anders reagieren ja heute die
antike wo nachdem ashley gebraucht und
wie sie andere 2 und sie haben ja sehr
verdreht sie das ist ja eine sieht
anders ist so ziemlich alles komme so
rechne man es anders machen
alba muss das gemisch schlägt wegnehmen
[Musik]
ursula priess vater ist 2010 gestorben
und auch auf der politischen bühne ist
seit der erstausstrahlung dieses films
vor sieben jahren viel passiert
der bundesrat entschuldigte sich 2010
bei den betroffenen drei jahre später
ebnete ein runder tisch den weg für die
finanzielle entschädigung der opfer
fürsorgerischer zwangsmaßnahmen mit dem
film lena erhält nun eine breite
öffentlichkeit einblick in die
schicksale zehn tausender betroffener
wie ursula biondi worden ist das dunkle
kapitel der schweizer geschichte so
viele eindeutige zieht immer noch an
willett ohne beute
[Musik]
doch das disney co
das hindelbank das was sich die klinik
st
das bleibt das ist empfehlen
das sieht die flashbacks oder shows von
neugeborenen babys da habe ich heute
noch mehr
das erinnere mich immer wieder dass im
inselspital wo es was man hungersnot
geschnitten 1
das heißt also erhöht immer wieder die
fleischmann das seele mine und die sind
jederzeit immer wieder explodieren
[Musik]
und das mit dem film jetzt und mit dem
ganzen politischer kampf jetzt und all
das was jetzt wo sie sage ich persönlich
habe das ziel erreicht es hat verdammt
weh tut immer noch weh wie der stadt hat
viel zwang zur quartett mittleren
entschuldigung ich wollte waren zwar gut
aber ich akzeptieren immer mehr wie ich
sehe was du suchst ist und glaubt vor
dem her kann ich langsam irina zufahrt
zum friedhof